[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir was
süßes und zwar so eine leckere griechen
und die dauer nicht lange ihr habt ein
bisschen wartezeit ja aber die
zubereitungszeit ist total schnell und
einfach gemacht und das ganze rezept ist
total praktisch und ihr bekommt viele
welchen raus 26 in der anzahl wenn es
genau wissen möchtet und jetzt zeige ich
euch zuallererst die zutaten für den
zuckersirup dafür benötigen wir diese
drei zutaten und zwar heißes wasser
zucker und etwas zitronensaft und wir
fangen jetzt direkt damit an dass wir
das heiße wasser mit dem zucker zusammen
vermischen
durch das heiße wasser löst sich der
zucker auf und wir brauchen diesen
unnötigen schritt nicht dass wir es auf
kochen und uns denn heute geht es um
schnelligkeit wir haben keine zeit und
jetzt gehen wir noch einen spritzer
zitronensaft treibt und dann ist er
zuckersirup auch schon fertig jetzt
kommen wir schon zum einfachen talk und
dafür benötigen wir folgende zutaten
weich weizen reis mehl butter die ist
geschmolzen etwas abgekühlt wie joghurt
ein ei backpulver und entweder den
abtrieb einer bio orange oder hier
dieses orangenaroma und jetzt geben wir
in eine schüssel dafür brauchen wir
jetzt auch kein handrührgerät oder
ähnliches gehen wir zuallererst die
flüssigen zutaten dann getrocknet und
dann wird alles miteinander verrührt da
gibt es gar keine richtige anleitung
hauptsache dass später alles ein teil
[Musik]
und irgendwann kommt selbst der beste
schneebesen nicht weiter hat da müssen
unsere hände benutzen ich habe mir jetzt
handschuhe angezogen und dann kneten wir
den teig nur noch mal für eine minute
bis alles schön geschmückt und wenn euer
teig dann richtig gut verbunden ist dann
habt ihr so ein richtig schön
geschmeidigen aber auch kompakten teig
und jetzt braucht ihr eine auflaufform
den ofen darf man steht hinter mir haben
da kann es mir die mit ihm geben mein
handy ist total fertig ist die einmal
gefallen für mich so der teig ist jetzt
schön geschmeidig kompakt und jetzt
können wir ihnen weiter verarbeiten ich
habe hier eine auflaufform die kommt
anschließend in den ofen also sollte die
ausreichend groß sein und auch ein
bisschen hoch und jetzt sticht ihr euch
immer kugeln ab und rollt die einmal und
anschließend welt sehen wir das ganze
noch mal in weizen gries und dann können
wir sie in die auflaufform legen
[Musik]
und sobald man den teig zu kugeln
geformt habt könnt ihr sie backen
ich sage euch noch mal kurz was zu
größter ich habs jetzt ein bisschen
kleiner als golfballgröße gemacht und
erhalte genau 26 stücks immer so immer
wenn ich das rezept macht und genau 26
stück wenn es kleiner macht dann
verringert sich auch ein bisschen die
backzeit da müsste einfach mal schauen
ich mag die hier jetzt bei 180 grad im
vorgeheizten backofen ist wichtig dass
der vorgeheizt für genau 40 minuten bis
sie richtig schön goldbraun sind nach
genau 40 minuten sehen unsere gries
kügelchen so aus also richtig schön
goldbraun und die jetzt müssen wir sie
mit dem kalten sirup übergießen
[Musik]
und wichtig ist dass ihr auf jede kugel
und nicht von dem zucker sirup darauf
gibt dass das jetzt 15 minuten einziehen
und dann machen wir weiter dann gehen
wir noch mal den rest trug aber das
zeige ich euch dann die griechen hatten
jetzt die möglichkeit den zuckersirup so
ein bisschen einzuziehen und jetzt geben
wir die zweite hälfte des zukaufs
nochmal auf die krebs bächen und drehen
das ganze dann um damit wirklich alles
voll gesaugt ist mit diesem zuckersirup
und das braucht es auch und ist es
wirklich nicht süß und es ist auch nicht
so matschig sondern total lecker ich
zeige später auf jeden fall nochmal den
anschnitt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der zucker sirup schön
eingezogen und unsere süßspeise ist
fertig dass da noch ein bisschen zucker
sirup in der auflaufform ist das ist
ganz normal also das zieht nicht
komplett ein aber wir brauchen trotzdem
die menge damit das halt so ein bisschen
von allen seiten einzigen kann jetzt
gebe ich das in meinem revier formen
oder da wo ich gern haben möchte und
dann werden wir das ganze noch mit
kokosraspeln bestreuen
ihr könnt aber gerne auch pistazie
nehmen oder gehackte walnüsse das
entscheidet ihr selber
und fertig sind sie unsere griff bächen
mit richtig schön kokos oben drauf ich
freue mich wenn ihr das ganze jetzt nach
macht geschmacklich sind die top ich
mache ich schon lange so wie schmecken
jedem und falls ihr jetzt die genauen
mengenangaben sucht die stehen alle
unten in der infobox falls das rezept
nach macht freue ich mich über fotos mit
dem hashtag kies kitchen auf instagram
und dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal
auf die couch setzen bevor ich mich
allerdings verabschieden wollte ich kurz
mitteilen dass hier schon das letzte
video der ramadan reihe
ich gehe raus aus der ramadan reihe mit
einem lachenden und einem weinenden auge
es hat mir richtig viel spaß gemacht nun
haben sie auch und deshalb also wirklich
toll und das ihr auch so vielleicht sich
alle die ganzen rezepte nach gemacht das
war unglaublich wurde überströmt mit
fotos und ich habe immer statisch
gesehen war auch richtig stolz ist er
meine rezepte nach gemacht habt jetzt
hoffe ich dass ihr so unseren weiteren
video auch einschaltet kommen
grillrezepte sommer rezepte eis alles
alles was das herz begehrt und wm das
ist auch ein ganz großes thema bei uns
die nächste zeit und dann freue ich mich
aufs nächste mal tschüss
[Musik]